so God how are you doing I'm very well
thank you how are you good
uh good I was just gonna say that I
think I speak for everyone at Collider
possibly the world
I know it's been a while but I say that
I miss I miss Kings - yes myself when
when will we see King Stach again
season 2 breaking think he could Rock a
moustache it may remove some of the
gravitas from him fair but we'll see I
would say would add gravitas it could be
like a slightly different version of
Kings - hey yeah hey someone throw a
hypothetical at you Oh
Witcher themed hypothetical okay if
someone was to hire growth of Rivia -
for a job and that job turned out to be
a Kryptonian mm-hmm who comes out of
that on top I see was like to me what I
would say hmm Superman Superman
absolutely amazing yeah garrets pretty
good yeah Garrett's
got if you give him a lot of prep time
like another fairly well-known mm-hmm
superhero character he may be in with
the chance but despite what you may have
seen in movies he only wins if Superman
holds back safeiy
what about August Walker what if he was
someone said can you take down this this
man talks walking uh West who has the
power of Kingston he does have the power
of Kings - I mean they could end up
being best buddies because I think the
same person
you never know Wow anything could happen
to miss she's that a spoiler for season
2 uh actually yes okay well cut that out
uh video there's a fight a specific
fight from the show an actual fight from
the show that I do wanna talk about and
since it's a bit of a spoiler I will not
will not post this until after the show
for me it's a the fight with the shtriga
in in episode 3 I believe yeah which is
a gnarly gnarly scene I kind of wanna
know the preparation for that and and
how and how that all came together
because it's a very complex physical
scene no I'm just wondering how you
approached it and
everyone approached it on the day how I
approach that the stunt team were
building a variety of wire rigs for some
of the big hits in there and the
choreography piece was fairly
straightforward as far as choreography
goes the wire rigs were the trickiest
piece and for me that was just about
jumping in getting involved as much as I
possibly could from the get-go much to
their dismay actually a points they're
like oh no we're going to kill the
actors not good mm-hmm but I loved it
and and it was all about I did I think I
had two or three rehearsals on each wire
rig before performing it for the actual
four camera and I I loved it like it's
it's all for me part of the journey of
telling a story and it's important for
me that the character lives within the
action and exists within the action it's
not just a performance and then it's
either me or a stunt performer doing
just a piece of action it has to all
blend into one and be part of the
storytelling and and I enjoyed having my
influence on that process